we have taken our 3d objects specified
its vertices relative to an origin in a
coordinate reference frame what happens
to a triangle to turn it from this
representation that we've got the
vertices the faces into pixels on the
screen we've got faces we can now
transform them by applying a
transformation at every vertex so we can
turn them and scale them and move them
around and but how does that now fit
into the bigger picture how do we go
from the local space of our 3d objects
in which its vertices are defined into a
2d representation on a screen well there
are several stages and they're all
transferred different transformations
that we apply the first one is from the
local object space of our representation
into world space so we pick an origin
for the world which I suppose we'll say
is the middle of the table and we then
apply a transformation which we specify
zahl of the vertices of our 3d object in
local space in terms of the world origin
so what we're basically doing is saying
well we want out there amid to be at
plus 1 in X or minus 1 and X minus 1 and
Z 2 in Y we can also then rotate it and
scale it if we like and we can do that
with several objects and move them all
to different places and each will have a
different transformation which places it
in the world it moves it from its local
space to world space and that is called
a world space transformation what we can
also do because we can combine
transformations together is specify one
object in terms of another so that we
can nest these different transformations
so that's we might want to stick
this pyramid to that one and and so it
has a first as a transformation that
moves it from its own local space
to the space of this pyramid which then
moves to the the world space wherever we
want to place it in the world and so we
can nest things that way all we need to
know really is where each vertex is in
the world we need to make world space
position all of the vertices then need
to be respective ID from world space in
terms of the space of the viewpoint if
the viewpoint is here say this is our
little camera and it's looking out on
the world as we turn the camera this way
what we actually do is apply a
transformation to everything in the
world which swings it's over this way so
the camera really never moves all we're
doing is applying a transformation that
appears to move everything relative to
the camera we're rece Pesa fiying all of
our objects in terms of the local space
of the camera and this is view space or
eye space if you like so it's really
it's just another transformation all
we're doing is moving from world space
into view space where Reis Pesa fiying
one coordinate frame of reference in
terms of another so just like we moved
from object space the local space of the
pyramid to world space where it was
positioned in our world we're now moving
from world space into view space which
is again just another transformation and
we can actually just combine those
transformations and have a a world view
transformation which combines both of
them into one and so all we need to do
is apply that operation every vertex on
every single shape we then need to
project down from 3d space into 2d space
which again it's just another
transformation everything is just
another transformation a projective
transformation is a little bit different
to the others because whereas before we
were just applying translations and
scales and rotations to move objects
from one
space to the next to the next now what
we have to do is have a special
transformation which removes all the
depth information from the ceiling
squashes all these vertices down onto a
2d plane and also because we might want
to have the perspective effect whereby
objects in the distance seem smaller you
need to collapse and scale them down
based on their distance and so on and so
forth and now all of that has encoded in
the projective transformation so yeah so
what we done we've we've taken our local
representation moved it into a world
space constructed the scene out of our
perimeter and there then moved all of
those relative to the eye so we know
exactly what's in front of us what's
going to be seen and then we collapse
all of those down and into two
dimensions so what happens to a triangle
to turn it from this representation that
we've got the vertices of faces into
pixels on the screen well let's just
draw some pixels out not very many
pixels the resolutions a bit low so
let's just take a random triangle and
draw it on let's draw it in purple so
here's our representation now it's been
squashed down into two dimensions and
what we now have to do to turn it into
pixels is go through every pixel here
and decide whether or not it's inside
the triangle now I've not drawn very
many pixels on here so it's not going to
look very good but we can say that this
one is pretty much inside the triangle
this one is pretty much inside the
triangle and for our given sake I'll go
with this one and this one and these two
as well and so now what we've done is
taken that simple geometric
representation and discretized it we've
turned it into a representation that no
longer has any information about said
vertices and faces it just says this
pixel is inside this triangle when we
collapse down from 3d to 2d and some of
the vertices are going to lie outside
our field of view
and in that case we need to clip them
what we have to actually do is generate
another two vertices here because we
don't know what's happening to this
because it's not part of our
representation anymore because we have
clipped it to the viewport as it's gold
the problem is now as you could see we
no longer got a triangle so well we just
use our old trick of turning an odd
polygon into the triangle representation
into two triangles and then the process
of deciding which pixels own triangle
proceeds but for these two new triangles
that now fit perfectly inside our
viewpoint that's called clipping and
then the next step beyond that is just
coloring in the pixels and deciding
exactly how to shade them and like them
we'd like to thank audible.com for their
support of this computer file video and
if you'd like to download one of their
huge range of books go to audible.com
slash computer file you can download one
for free I'd like to recommend one today
my favorite computer related book and
one of the first books that made me
think hang on computers could be cool
and that's Neuromancer by William Gibson
so get on to audible.com slash computer
file download your free book and thanks
again to audible.com for supporting this
computer file video working in 3d will
incorporate the table into this because
this is where the shadow is being cast
the table is another 3d object in our 3d
Louisville and we're doing a shear
operation in four dimensional space